let me promise everyone here
you want to win in 2021 be nicer
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
welcome gary vaynerchuk to datto kickoff
2021
i am so happy to be here and thank you
so much clearly
uh clearly you spoke to my mom before
that intro
um you're very very sweet thank you
thank you everybody for having me i'm
extremely excited to uh get into this
talk and really
to be frank get into the q a because i
love the practicality of that so we'll
be getting to that in the back end
for some of you that don't know me um i
i am
a kind of born entrepreneur back to the
lemonade stand franchise and sports
cards which are back by the way now
um in my teenage years and you know my
family lived the american dream i was
born in the soviet union
um we came to this country with so
little we lived in studio apartment with
you know my grandma my great-grandma my
great-grandfather like real real
immigrant stuff
and um and we kind of made our way you
know my parents quickly had a second
child
my sister liz and it was a grind there
in the late 70s early 80s but my dad
had a great uncle who had a liquor store
and he gave him a job and
he built himself up and eventually
became the manager and eventually
um bought his own store in springfield
new jersey
by the time i was 14 i did have those
you know eight nine years of sales
marketing and branding experience and
i'm not kidding you know it's funny
knowing the audience for this talk
you know i think of myself as a salesman
i think of myself as
a ceo i think of myself as a marketing
and brand person
and i think all of them matter and i
think they all have interesting
um different nuances different things
that you start with
different kpis different energies but i
think all of them have something to
take out of this world which i'll get
into in a minute and i think a lot of
people
on this call don't realize why producing
two different videos
or pictures or written words a day on
linkedin
can really change their career
financially and to be very frank
happiness and we'll get into that in a
minute so you know by the time i was 14
i felt like i was a pro you know
singing christmas carols for a dollar
shoveling snow i was a very unique kid
that
when it snowed or when this summer
started my initial reaction was it
snowed
oh let's get shovels ring doorbells make
two bucks
five bucks later ten bucks when it first
day of summer it's like let's get our
lemonade game on let's go
i mean i remember my friend marissa bird
carrying a huge
hose twice a week in the summer because
we were gonna be washing cars for five
bucks
it was just always there and my lemonade
business
you know i learned how to manage kids i
mean this is just real now it's 7 89
years old i learned how to
motivate my friends aka manipulate and
trick them into standing behind
a table for six hours in the summer to
sell lemonade
but i learned what the power of
marketing and branding intention i
literally this is crazy to me in
hindsight i i had the epiphany actually
on stage
somewhere in my late 30s that this is
what i did because i i would always tell
the lemonade story and i was like
why you know what did i do when they
were behind the tables
and i was like wait a minute i was
making signs and going around the
neighborhood this was the 80s where
six-year-olds could run free i would
walk around the neighborhood
and put up signs i would even sit
and watch cars drive by and try to
figure out which
tree or which post would be most likely
seen by the driver
so that they would buy my lemonade and
at
seven years old eight years old in 1982
and 83 i
clearly started my obsession and my
curiosity around customers attention
that played out huge in my baseball card
business because the way i set up my
tables was very
get people's attention when they were
walking through the convention or the
firehouse or the mall
and then it really was an impact on my
dad's business and the way that i set up
the store when i first got there and
moved things around and
maximized our business by impacting
people buying more things because it was
merchandised better
i watched customers i watched customers
i watched customers from 14 to 22.
i worked in that liquor store behind the
register bagging ice
stocking shelves and i just watched
people how they walked what they picked
listening to them talking to them
listening listening listening listening
listening listening
and realizing that if i could bring them
what they wanted
more so than what i wanted out of it if
i had compassion empathy
sympathy to them not to my greed
or ambition or self-interest that i
would have leverage
right think about right now the person
in your company or in your life
that you most value right think about
that person
that person is providing you value
that's why and think about how much
leverage that person has right think
about the fact that that person
because they bring you so much value has
leverage in your relationship like you
don't want them
to stop doing what they're doing you
don't want them to leave quit
you don't want them to break up with you
and so i really think that kindness is
the ultimate leverage that bringing
value is the ultimate leverage and i
think about that
constantly and i think about that in
sales leadership
marketing um i launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses for my dad
in 1996 winelibrary.com
as a matter of fact if you are into wine
please go to winetexttext.com right now
i just stood up a new thing for my dad
18 months ago that's changed his life
it's a daily deal via text on wine
it's completely changed his business and
the reason i'm bringing it up is twofold
one i love my dad
and i don't think and i and i i love my
dad actually three reasons one
i love my dad the most and i'd like you
to buy wine from him two
it's the damn best wine service on the
internet today we're
selling a 65 cabernet for 26.
so that's good that's good for you but
three and most importantly
i want all of you to learn text
marketing i think sms
is emerging and one thing i want to
leave this talk with is
clubhouse and sms and tick tock and
linkedin changes
i'm a practitioner i'm not an author or
speaker
i happen to be one but the reason i'm a
good one
is because i'm a practitioner i spent 12
14 hours a day
operating something called vaynerx and
vaynermedia which is a marketing and
communications infrastructure company
and and and i have the garyvee thing
right i'm producing content on a daily
basis
these are really remarkable
variables in the fact that i believe a
lot of authors are intellects
i believe a lot of speakers are
educators and i think that's amazing and
i love that
but i genuinely enjoy the fact that i'm
living your life
all of you whether it's sales whether
it's management whether it's marketing
whether it's leadership and iu 2021 is
the greatest opportunity
era of all time i literally believe that
2021 for our businesses
selling sas selling hardware selling
hoodies is the best year ever to do
business because the advancements of
technology the lack of gatekeepers
controlling
what you can and can't do the
environment
the ecosystem i think people focus so
much on the negative whether it's
political unrest whether it's
um you know overwhelming with technology
whether it's self-esteem issues
and mental health issues and i think all
of those things are true
i also believe that in life you see
what you're looking for
in life i believe you see what you're
looking for and for me
i think the word optimism is grossly
misunderstood
i believe that cynical people unhappy
people
look at the word optimism and they think
it's delusion
but the reason there's a word in the
dictionary called delusion
and the reason there's a word in the
dictionary called optimism is because
they're wildly different
i come from immigrant beginnings i'm
always scared to go back to that place
right
subconsciously i don't feel it but it's
clearly there
it makes me uncomfortably practical
however i fear no one step or two steps
or three steps backward i don't
overvalue money
it allows me to innovate it allows me to
figure out things
earlier i built one of the largest
e-commerce and retail wine businesses in
america as a 22 23 24 year old
in a world where the internet was still
small in a world where i had no venture
capital money
in a world where i out executed everyone
and it was completely religious about
what can i do for you
period end of story which led to
delivery
from the internet is more convenient
than driving 45 minutes to my dad's
store
it meant when somebody had a bad
delivery i would throw a case of
behringer white zinfandel in my car and
drive 40 minutes and deliver it even if
fedex screwed up
it meant that when an employee looked
sad i asked them are you okay
and when they said their mom was like i
said go home i got this
like let me promise everyone here you
want to win
in 2021 be nicer
you want to win in 2021 have more
compassion
you want to lead in 2021 lead with this
not with what your head thinks your
wallet is going to benefit from
and i know that i'm sounding fluffy and
but let there be no confusion i'm an
assassin when it comes to business
you may be hearing fluffy things but let
me get real close to the camera here my
friends
i'm trying to win the whole thing i'm
trying to be the greatest entrepreneur
of all time
i believe that kindness compassion
empathy sympathy
first for your employees then for your
customers and then
you can think about yourself is not
mother teresa stuff
it's not gandhi nelson mandela stuff
i believe that it is sheerly and
obviously
the foundation of successful business in
today's transparent
universe you're meanness
that you think is motivating it
can't be hidden the way it used to be
and so
i want people to lead with optimism
kindness
and all these kind of soft skills
because i think they're the emerging
superpowers
of business and i think a lot of you
should really be paying attention to it
i also think that
all of these things that we're talking
about can be scaled right
so my career is going along nicely and
then
and i'm winning on email marketing 90
open rates
and i'm winning on google adwords the
day comes out i'm buying every wine term
that's working for my dad
and then comes along youtube
and i see this platform and i say to
myself there's something here
and you can't run ads on it on the top
at the time
so i decided to do a show
and i never thought of myself this gift
of you know i thought of myself the gift
of gab but more like
a good salesman or you know a class
clown that the teacher kind of liked you
know
and so i didn't realize what i was going
to be able to do
in that format but i started a very big
show that garnered
a lot of attention and it really really
worked
and it really got going and it really
taught me oh my god i don't have to
spend marketing money
this attention is trickling down
organically
to my dad's business there's something
here and then twitter came out and i
start using it to promote
wine library tv and i'm like oh my god
this friendster myspace thing is about
to become much bigger this so sure
it wasn't called social media yet it was
called web 2.0
twitter was known as a web 2.0 app and
i started using it and google buys
youtube for 1.7 billion dollars
and i say to myself oh my god i was
right about this i was right about
google adwords i was right about
email i'm bet i'm not a wine retailer i
understand what people are going to do
i need to become an investor and what i
think people are going to do in 2007 i
invested in facebook twitter and tumblr
and that obviously changed my life my
brother was graduating from college
i was starting to make videos about
business that were catching people's
attention
and in 2009 i decided to start
vaynermedia to do marketing for the
biggest brands in the world so i could
learn big business because i understood
silicon valley
i understood small business
entrepreneurship but i didn't understand
executive fortune 500 land and i didn't
understand why they were doing so many
silly things in a world where i thought
netflix
facebook amazon were going to be the
next big thing and they turned out to be
way bigger than i even
kind of predicted even though i was
predicting the tippy top and so
that's been my career i've written five
new york times best-selling books around
marketing
and um and consumer behavior
and psychology but what does all this
hyperbole around me mean
it means that i believe
that every person who's watching this
right now
is me in 2009. here's what i mean by
that
i had a level of success i was good
i was enjoying myself i was building a
big company for my parents
i was excited to think about what i was
going to do for myself next
but the scale of the internet by using
the tools
completely changed my life and i believe
that what the internet does is exposes
things so i don't think the internet
changed me
i don't think it made me nicer and
stronger at my craft
i think it made more people aware that i
was nice and strong in my craft
and so i think for everybody who's
watching right now i don't think they
realize that if they started producing
content on linkedin
about what they know not what you think
people want not to get followers
but to put out content of what you know
story tell
my grandpappy taught me when i was 10
this i now did this for my salesperson
today that's the video
you don't have to be an expert i'm not
an expert i'm a person that has
hypotheses and opinions
and because a lot of them became true
after 15 years
and i've put the actual business wins on
the board
now people look at me in a different way
but i don't even you know even the
flattering introduction
and our talk beforehand you know she
makes me feel so good
but i don't think that makes me special
i think it's just a nice
feeling to be admired you know uh
and and i think when you layer humility
and curiosity
around being good at a tool great things
happen let me give you an example
when books came out yeah i'm being
serious now when books came out
clearly and i have no knowledge of this
but this is very easy to understand
clearly there were individuals who
became more aggressive at reading them
and amassed knowledge and my intuition
is
the ones that were able to be practical
and operating
were able to do something with that
knowledge and succeed
when tractors and innovation
hit farming the people that didn't
demonize it and many did
many said that's not real farming
because they were fearful that it was
going to take away jobs from their
people which was a nice thing
but they were trying to fight technology
which is always the wrong answer
let there be no confusion if you hear or
feel anything from this keynote and q
a today please let it be this if you are
fighting against technology
you will lose it is the history of
mankind
tractor comes along people fought
against it the humans that adopted it
learned it and used it best built the
biggest farms
cnn and espn and mtv did this
to regular television and society
facebook and aol and and you know google
did it to their growth in social the
personalities that tried to build brand
in the
mid 2000s personal brands they've gone
on to do things like
this is just too obvious that the
breakthrough in our humanity today
whether you want to run for mayor
whether you want to build a big business
whether you want to cure cancer whether
you want to raise some money for the pta
it is around content and it's around you
being self-aware
and you worrying it's there's two words
self-awareness and self-esteem
if you're self-aware you don't try to do
things you can't do
you focus on things you do like you
don't try to be something you're not
if you have self-esteem you're not
scared to put it out
the content the video the picture the
audio
because you're not worried if
sallypants49 thinks you're ugly
you're not worried that rick thompson
from a competitive company says you're
stupid
you're just not worried you're not
worried that you have bags under your
eyes
or you're overweight or you're losing
your hair you're just not worried
you're you're focused on your
self-esteem you're focused on yourself
you're focused on your self-awareness
which puts you in a position to succeed
and so all of you
one of the worst not worst one of the
challenging times in my career was
around 2012 when people all wanted to be
like me
and i'm a very very over-the-top
high-energy personality
who's very very comfortable on video
and that is just not going to be the
case for everybody and i tell everybody
and it took me a while to get to this
good answer which i think has helped
people listen my friends
if you're watching this right now and be
like okay i see what gary's setting up
he's going to ask me to start producing
a lot more content that's the answer by
the way
well i don't want to do video well i'm
like good news sarah
you don't have to do video you might for
example i'm a terrible writer
if i was a great writer i'd be writing a
lot more
because writing on linkedin crushes as a
matter of fact my team loves when i
i write all the copy on my instagram
posts right all of them
everyone every post in my life and they
get pumped when i get motivated
and like write a real good one because
we know the post does better
copy is the most underrated thing in
social media today
it drives so much of the success of the
picture in the video
so by the way you might be an audio
you might be a talker but you're
insecure about your visual of how you
look
or the camera makes you freeze but
you're great with talking so good
there's now clubhouse an incredible app
you can go and be a thought leader in
there's just recording audio and posting
that on your linkedin
linkedin for this group knowing who's in
the room
is equivalent to what facebook was in
2012
that will lead to incredible financial
and emotional
success to those in here that heed the
call that i'm yelling today
period end of story i could not be more
passionate
about everybody here getting very
serious and then what you put out
is up to you you know my recommendation
is that it brings value to people
whether it's entertaining whether it's
informational
but i also believe that stories stories
are
easier for people this is something that
i'm going to start talking a lot about
a lot more about i think stories
just stories like life lessons grandma
told me
and then if you're good at and i've
already talked brought this up i'm gonna
bring it up again because i'm trying to
help everybody here give you some
training wheels
if you say hi i'm karen i'm a sales lead
at this company
i this is for my team but honestly this
is for the broader world because all you
sales leaders i know how it is
you know when i was nine my grandmother
took me
to a girl scouts event and sarah johnson
did this and my grandma i did this and
grandma told me to do that and then i
did this and me and sarah johnson were
best friends in high school
and that's ironic because i had a big
tiff between
carl and carla recently on my team and i
did this like my grandma did that and
now they just closed the biggest account
together
that story that should come very natural
and by the way you don't need to call
out carl and carla
right because that's active you're in
the world right now you could be two
people on my team
just think about how easy that is for
what everyone's struggling with which is
well what do i post what do i post is
grounded in lack of self-esteem
and lack of strategy
period and so
i'm here today to build your self-esteem
and not in a delusional way i'm just
trying to encourage you to realize how
real this is because the
content creators that build awareness
and audiences will have the leverage in
business whether it's a small narrow
world
and by the way this is a small narrow
sector most of the business people on
this call in this thing that's great
actually
the reality is that's great because then
you run a couple dollars in ads on
linkedin against targets of companies
that are in your sector
and you're getting exactly who you want
i actually like
when groups are narrow because you can
get so much more specific
so anyway i'm just very excited to be
here i
want to encourage everyone to realize
the opportunity
the internet is not a gatekeeper you
know there there's so many platforms
there's people talking about big tech
you can build outside of big tech all
day long there's so much going on
um and there's just so much opportunity
so much opportunity and i hope you see
it
and i hope you understand the the
emotional intelligence needed to attack
it
and i hope that you start to educate
yourself practically and i think the
reason i like to set up
q a for a big portion of this is this is
the macro thesis
be practical and optimistic produce
content at scale around stories
information entertainment and knowledge
bring as much value to your community
rinse and repeat in perpetuity for 15
years that's the thesis
now the question becomes what are the
specifics underneath it and i think this
is a good segue to get into the q
a so thank you for having me and i think
we're going to get into the meat
right now of this keynote and i'm
excited and by the way any of you that
are on here right now my twitter is
garyvee
since i'm not tapped into a chat or
anything like this sometimes i like to
just get a vibe or questions on that
format while i'm doing live streams so
garyvee if you
if you just uh tweet at me and just say
any feedback or
questions i can weave it into my answers
a little bit here while i get these
incredible questions so thank you so
much
everybody i'm ready to keep going
thank you gary that was absolutely
fantastic
we really appreciate your time and your
generosity and i cannot wait to dive
into these questions
um so we'll take a step back for a
minute and first ask you
how are you doing as we head into 2021
and how did 2020 change
kind of your everyday and and your
company
i'm doing great thank you for asking um
you know
it you know i stopped traveling as much
i got more sleep i put on 15 pounds of
muscle
so i'm super pumped about that um uh
you know family time got a tremendous
amount of time with my parents which i
think
is something i'll look back on as a
great blessing of this time
um you know it uh
it actually allowed me to focus very
heavily on vayner media and vayner x
which i think led us to a much stronger
foundation of success
going forward so i'm grateful for that
um
i got to work on something called the
all in challenge where michael rubin the
founder of fanatics
stood up a non-profit concept that i
helped him on and strategized on and
then executed on
which ended up being a 60 million dollar
raise for the hungary during covid
so i got this between that and pence as
a promise you know i got to really
kind of scratch the give back part of my
life
um it allowed me to stand up something
called tea with gary vee a show that i
did
during covet and i'm actually going to
bring back
it let me but but i miss traveling
and i miss interacting with people in a
face-to-face environment but it did
allow me to long-term
be more efficient in my business know
when to use video versus in person
both for internal and external and i
think that's going to make me much
stronger and more
happy and successful in 2022 2023 2024
yeah absolutely what if what about from
a sales perspective did 2020
impact or change how your sales
organization works or
do you see lasting impact for businesses
on a whole
based on what happened last year um
[Music]
i just think last year exposed
everything
you know outside of restaurants and you
know they're clearly
some haves and have-nots winners from a
covet environment
but i think i think for me it was just
about um
it was just about focus and reality and
practicality and just a lot of great
learnings
yeah i think one of the things that get
came up in a lot of your videos
throughout covid and for those of you
who are watching
um throughout 2020 was that optimism
that you brought up at the beginning of
this conversation and i think it's so
important because when you ask about
well how was your 2020
you pulled out all of the good things
just now when you answered
and not any negatives um and i think
that's really interesting but it's also
a lesson that we can all take away
so i don't want to take away from the
challenges of 2020 at all
yeah and i'm sorry to interrupt it's a
really interesting observation
right because to your point to me my
greek grandmother and grandmother
came from the old country and really
almost every time they drank tea
or when the men were drinking vodka
you'd always kind of
do this thing where you spoke to good
health you know everything was to good
health
to good health to good health i think it
brainwashed me in the greatest way of
all time
i for me 2020
is a year that has incredible
underlining pain for a lot of people who
feel that they were robbed of years
with people they love i am one of the
lucky people that did not have that
happen
and so thus after that
you know vayner speakers and and vayner
productions
took massive hits lost millions of
dollars doesn't register
because that's business that's almost
like not real life like money is not
real life
real life is very basic do the 12 15
20 people i love did they live in 2020
and yes amazing best year ever
and and you know i also am a good
operator but i will say this
if i owned 15 restaurants it would have
been
and we were mandated to close now from
my perspective because i always
believe in innovation i believe my dash
and uber eats and direct to consumer
would have been stood up already
and i probably would have grown and and
and i think it forced a lot of
restaurants to finally do the right
things
uh and so it's just a really interesting
time if you're a capable
operator and you have life in a
simplistic mindset
you're going to be happy way more often
yeah i think that's a great point and
something we can all take away from this
is
to choose the good right when we're
faced with those
those difficult challenges it's not the
challenge that defines us but how we get
through it and how we innovate and how
we adapt
at the end of the day um and so i'd like
to jump into some tactical questions
um and we what's nice about this
audience is we're kind of a mix right we
have sales
support marketing implementation success
we're all here together um so some of
the questions will
mean more to teams than the others but i
think we can all learn from these
um so in one way or another we're all
content creators
right we have our content team for sure
um
but training and implementation creates
training videos
for our partners sales is constantly the
face of the company
and creating content in one way or the
other so what's the greatest lesson in
terms of content
that you've learned over the years that
you might want to share
with the team when you're a sales driven
organization the most
important thing to do with content is
make it brand
content on the internet is everyone
hears opportunity to offset the
aggressiveness of what is sales
it's an opportunity to provide value to
the audience it's a
way to provide affinity towards you and
your company
by showing the humanity aka silly things
like just think of the office the tv
show
like if you have somebody funny in your
company named ricky like get ricky on
video because it
shows a different side to what
everyone's accustomed to which is the
cold
linkedin the cold email the cold call
the very quick to hey let's do business
at a conference
so the biggest thing i've learned for
sales driven organizations which is
amazing i love sales driven
organizations
you know is thinking about content as
your appetizer
to the sales being the meal if you have
a great appetizer you're setting up a
great meal and so i think the biggest
mistake i see it over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
in these dynamics is that people use
content as a sales engine
instead of a brand engine nike
doesn't cold call you or knock on your
door and ask you to buy
you know their sneakers and even when
you think about salesforce and sap
even though they have great sales dna
and infrastructure there's so much
brand going on for a reason you need to
have
that offset right you need to have that
honey to the vinegar you need to have
that good cop to the bad cop
content on linkedin is the good cop
and i think that is a very difficult
maneuver for the dna of most of the
people that are watching this right now
period and that's okay that doesn't mean
you're bad
doesn't mean you're stupid it means that
there's a humongous
uncomfortable monstrous opportunity that
if you heed the strategy of what i'm
talking about
and start implementing it like why not
do an hour of q a on linkedin
and just answer questions everyone's so
fear-based
and so like lack of you know people are
not abundant
right like i give away all my best
advice i'm not scared of somebody
starting another agency
or another agency taking it like it
doesn't matter the world's abundant i'm
going to get mine
why do you think it is that people in
sales driven organizations might have
that fear
and what advice can you give to kind of
overcome it
because like you said there's this
monstrous opportunity but sometimes
there's a lot of hesitation there
almost everybody thinks that resources
are limited and they have and almost
everybody has a boss i don't have a boss
so it's easy for me to talk this way
you know i have empathy and compassion
for somebody who's listening right now
and does a seminar and gives away a lot
of great advice
and their boss coming to them and saying
what the hell are you doing that's like
how we get clients and then they get
fired or lose their bonus or
are pegged down in the organization
unfortunately fear is remarkably
effective
and a real human trait um
i just don't believe in it and so what i
you know i just believe that there's so
much more
financial and by far
there's more financial but by far
there's so much more happiness on the
back
of going with optimism and abundance as
your mindset and so
i think it's culture i think it's the
industry culture
for many many many many years and
i think that business has historically
had a cold
you know kill or be killed kind of
mentality
and you know i think of sports a little
bit
i think business more like sports i as a
fan
get so angry after a jets game when my
jets
lose and they go and hug all their
friends on the other team because i'm
pissed
but the reality is i actually fully
understand it i want to kill
crush destroy defeat outmaneuver
everybody i compete with at every second
it is my dna
however not at the detriment of their
lives
like i want to do 10 trillion and i want
you to do 9 trillion
and that's how i think and i i wish more
people realized how real that is and how
true that can be
um and that's what i think about
great thank you so much i think
something something else you mentioned
that i want to pull on
a little bit is you mention nike and how
they go about doing what they do
and i think a really interesting thing
for us is we're a business to business
organization um and i think a lot of
companies in that b2b world say
okay we're b2b so we're going to do
marketing and sales
the way b2b should do it but there's so
many lessons we can learn from the b2c
world
and i think you know there's hesitation
to step outside of that box and do
something a b2c company might do
so what lessons can we learn from b2c to
help us differentiate ourselves in the
market
um first of all b2c uh
is just far more creative because they
don't use the laziness of well we're in
b2b
we can't do that as an excuse
let's just start with that you know i
think um
i think that b2b marketing to me is
actually more exciting than b2c
marketing because i think linkedin is in
this 2012 to 14 facebook place
and i think the impact of winning
something in b2b is so much greater than
b to c
so i put out a good you know right hook
in this keynote to winetext.com
right and four people sign up and that's
awesome right however
if vaynermedia got a client out of this
call for boehner talent or
sasha group that's so much more
significant that's like 4 000 5 000
people signing up for wine text
i think the stakes are so high in b2b
marketing and i think b2b marketing the
way it's supposed to be
or has been done is garbage like
spending money at a conference where you
see the same people like you
like cool but like like people are
spending real money on booths
and real money on full-page ads and
print in b2b magazines
like let's listen let's speak to the
elephant in the room
the b2b industry for the most part
especially if they do under
250 million in top line revenue a year
they're not in the marketing business
they're in the sales business it's all
sales
marketers get made fun of in b2b
environment because they don't
prove their value yet
i stand here today and i will be one of
the greatest businessmen of all time and
i know it to be true
and it's because of the way my mother
parented me but i can't show you the
chart
or the search query or the
data point that proves that i just know
it to be true
we have people in b2b sales who make fun
of marketers
who say prove to me that worked that
believe in god
i'm just going to say it one more time
have people this is what this was one of
my favorite moments in
my career this is why i'm bringing it up
i was in a uh
might have been a keynote or a
conference but it was a nice little
dinner of 8 10 very smart people
and a very big b2b company and the one
guy was ahead of sales and one gal was
head of marketing
and he was going at her and i was kind
of like not going at her very mean or
inappropriately but like
he was razzing like we do the real [ __ ]
you get to have fun waste money right
and i'm listening and i'm eating and you
know and then he started getting a
little bit into bully territory
and i kind of looked at him and the
gentleman was wearing a big cross
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna put a flag in the ground in
this debate i go sir
i go john i go um
you believe in god he goes
the most more than any [ __ ] person
here i believe in god the most
i go cool so karen
you're saying does all these things but
it's waste because she can't prove that
it works right
yeah i go just do me a huge favor right
now
prove to me god exists it was one of the
most interesting conversations in my
career
i am fascinated how people don't
understand that branding and marketing
is the most important
does it have the difficulties to be
judged that sales doesn't of course it
does that's why i love sales
sales is black and white i gary sold 19
things yay
i gary the marketer have been doing
things for 15 years that nobody could
understand
yet i sit here today with the luxury of
the beautiful
accolades that you gave me coming here
this wonderful audience that's leaving
comments left and right
the you know nine figures of
financial success that i've created at a
young age and i haven't even started
all because of marketing and branding so
it's a very powerful conversation
thank you so much and i think i want to
give a shout out to the sales and
marketing team
um together because i think that's why
we have these meetings is to bring us
together
so we can work collaboratively as a team
and i think uh
everything that gary's saying is
something we can definitely take away
from this conversation
um i think one of the other things that
we want to talk about so you
brought up cold calling a little bit
just a few moments ago
and we do have individuals on our team
that that's part of their job is the
cold calling
so how what advice can you give to them
and
how do you go about cold calling in this
environment
and do it in a creative way where you
can really get someone's attention
because it is a little more difficult
than if we you have all those
you know marketing leads or you have a
relationship with somebody already
look you have to know the mission you're
on right there's some people
that are part of an army that go into
enemy lines without guns
during vietnam and were part of that
squad that you know and
that um you know that was a very
different mission than being a general
back at the fort
right or being somebody with the guns
back at the
you know at the precinct so to me um
cold calling is an incredible challenge
let there be no confusion
i think nobody here is confused very few
people are fired up in 2021 to get a
cold call
at the same token it is something that
works
there are people who have charisma charm
strategy um i think the number one
answer to cold calling is compassion
if you establish the person that just
picked up the phone
within the first 30 seconds three
seconds nine seconds
that you are understanding that is
likely that they are not excited
to hear you however you genuinely your
soul believe you have something to bring
to the table
i think that is the feeling you need to
pass on within those first six seconds
and i would tell the people that on the
front lines of cold calling
don't apologize under you know don't
don't don't be depressed so many people
reach out to me like gary i have to cold
call like that's okay
it's awesome and then other people are
like cold calling's the best because
they're awesome at it
it's a it's a very narrow thing they've
got that thick skin and they're just a
machine you know and so you know i think
i think a don't be apologetic and find
compassion
and then b if you're crushing it and you
love it add some things to your
repertoire
including it's wonderful that you're
just a machine and unemotional and you
eventually get
six well if you deployed compassion
empathy in the first six seconds you
might get 39
out of those thousand calls
and so the point um that you bring up
about compassion kind of understanding
the person that you're talking to
really knowing where they're coming from
what they need that's a big theme for us
this week this year
you know know your msp the managed
service providers that we that we serve
and i know it's something you talk a lot
about in your content
is understanding your audience and
really knowing them
um i'd love to hear a little bit more
from you about the importance of that
and we we always say we put our partners
first but
how can we go about doing that in a
bigger way in 2021 and how do you go
about doing that
um at vayner x and vayner media we ask
them what they value the most
some value us paying them more some
value
us having me give them a shout out
because they need brand
some value coming in and learning how to
do marketing in exchange
part barter to them being a partner
you know bringing value comes down to
listening
when you decide the value you're going
to give someone you're not
providing value you're giving what you
want to give
that's a very different relationship
than asking someone what they want
and then being able to figure out how to
provide it and by the way
if you have kind candor when somebody
says something you can't provide you can
also articulate that there are people
ask me for things all the time
that in my early 20s i would dodge
because i didn't want to be mean
and that led me to be not the man i
wanted to be it wasn't bad but it wasn't
stand up
enough and now in my older age i'm like
look i can't do that karen
that's not in the best interest of what
i want to be doing and so
i think kind candor on the back of
listening as a communication to your
partners
will lead to dramatically more fruitful
events
and i think part part of knowing our
partners for so we're talking about
sales and marketing a lot but we have a
ton of support people here we have
implementation people here
um so i'd love to talk about support and
really understanding
our partners in that way understanding
your audience and how we can
add more value once they're they become
a customer
i know you have a great story um about
the liquor store and someone who got a
jersey in the mail
i don't want to give it away yeah this
is huge i would love for you to tell
that story or any other similar stories
um
let me tell this one this one's really
good because i think creativity
is the way to really win the b2b game
and this was a very creative b2c
example that i do in b2b land all the
time now
if all of you had 49 targets to do
business with
your ability to follow them on linkedin
and twitter most likely
instagram as well potentially is very
high you hit follow
if you then read what they're interested
in and what they love in life
you now have an opportunity to create a
connection point sending somebody a
bottle of dom perrion and saying we'd
love for you to consider us
may not land if they are rehabbing from
alcoholism
may not land if they just don't like
champagne may not land with me who
really knows about wine
and doesn't want that champagne wants
something smarter and cooler
you didn't know anything about me i know
that you just send bottles of champagne
to everybody that's a big wig not gonna
land
intent didn't land because i know that
i don't mean anything to you you're
trying to get me through this thing
however
let me paint you a different story so
i'm writing this book called the thank
you economy back in 2011
and it talks about providing value and i
remember thinking you know
i'd like a little bit more tangible and
you know
example it didn't work out for me it
didn't make the book
but it's here i am a decade later about
to tell the story
i called wine library and i said hey the
next time
you get a first time customer place an
order i want you to take the name i want
you to go to twitter search
and i want to see if you can actually
find the person
so it took a while because most people
just weren't on twitter at the time
and more importantly most people didn't
have unique enough names or put where
they were from it just took a while
before we finally found a person with a
unique enough name
who lived in chicago and on their
twitter account and said they lived in
chicago it was a unique enough name we
kind of thought we had our person right
and so we monitored what he was talking
about
so here's this gentleman who buys a case
of pinot grigio i remember it like
yesterday
and all he talks about is jay cutler
jay cutler was the former quarterback of
the chicago bears and he is just on it
jay cutler this he's the best
so team calls me and says hey good news
we got one
we got this guy in chicago he's a huge
jay cutler fan i go great
i go why you go to ebay and buy a jay
cutler signed jersey
i'm on the phone i'm about to get on a
plane i remember it like yesterday um
and he he they said gary that's like 400
bucks
and what he bought was 180 case that
we're making nine dollars on
after shipping and i'm like uh-huh
lesson time i got the teacher i go do it
so we buy it we send it we say thank you
from
wine library thank you for joining our
family uh hope you enjoy the pinot
grigio
so now i'm pumped right i'm like wait
till this guy gets it
he's gonna post it on twitter he's gonna
call up
two months later nothing i like check if
we had the right address about a month
later when i remembered
and i'm so sad because i thought this
was going to be so epic
we did some other little ones got some
little stuff here and there
and then i get a phone call it's funny i
travel a lot
ironically again getting on a plane this
time i was actually on the plane like
walking in sat down in my seat
and and the team says to me hey we have
some great news
do you remember the jay cutler thing
i'll go yeah he what'd he do
he goes not him get this so they go on
to say gary
somebody just placed a six thousand
dollar order for burgundy
blinds very high-end stuff
i'm like cool what's that what and
let us read you the note that he put in
the notes field that's usually for gift
notes but he wrote something else which
was
dear wine library uh first of all please
hold these wines because they're
expensive and it's a little hot here in
florida i want you to
you know you know wait it's florida or
texas i don't call it the time but like
we have warm weather can you hold the
wines two you have an incredible
burgundy selection i'm also looking for
romani conte and this and that you know
can you please reach out to me
three uh a couple months ago a friend of
mine
let's just call him don don received
a jay cutler signed jersey in the mail
after he bought some wine from you
um hey that's incredible b
i'm a huge bruce springsteen fan have a
good day
to me yeah to me
that was just unbelievable to me that
was
everything i believe in which is doing
the right thing is always the right
thing
we clearly showed a human being we went
out of our way to get to know them and
do something special
surprised and delighted that created
word of mouth not on the internet like
we anticipated but in his
circle led to somebody becoming aware of
our business
and led to this moment
that's called business and i think
everybody who's watching right now
has 50 to 100 people they're targeting
to do business with i couldn't recommend
more
for them to follow their interests and
engage with people around their
interests
whether it's sending them a you know a
violin with a note attached to it
whether it's just replying to them
around the things they like because they
also love dave matthews band
and that they'll nerd out on that and
that will lead this is about humanity
this is about what you would do
if you were in the same country club or
the or part of the same elks club
or part of the same book club with
somebody that potentially you could do
business with you would be human
and you would win around human
interactions i just believe that this
scales your ability to do it with 200
people instead of two
yeah and i think that's something every
single one of us can take away
whether we're in marketing sales support
success you know we're all interfacing
with partners in different ways
and that's something we can take away
and there's a great example of that the
first time i ever went to an msp trade
show
i was at a table with a bunch of ceos
that we serve
at managed service providers we talked
about business for 10 minutes
we talked about star wars for an hour
and a half and it was just
that human connection and i think
there's so many opportunities
for each one of us regardless of our
role to really act on on what you're
saying gary and make those human
connections
um i know we only have a few minutes
left let me just say one more thing i
apologize
no go for it let's not demonize
technology which a lot of people are
doing
because they want to use it as an excuse
to not do it realize that technology is
the gateway
to real interaction and your life will
change
absolutely absolutely and i um we just
have a couple minutes so i'm gonna pick
one question here we have a
a lot of good ones but we're growing as
a company it's very exciting to see
where we're going
um and i think how do we one of the big
questions that we had from
multiple people actually was how do we
keep teams motivated
and keep the culture the culture the
company culture at the same time as we
scale and become much bigger
the answer is listening and i'll give
you the practical execution
do obnoxious amounts of coffees happy
hours
random pop-up or after hours zooms
with your people talk
engage like it's like when
it's like children if children feel like
their parents are in it
they end up being better people it's not
super complicated make your people know
that you're in it with them have
meetings be with them
do random fun stuff have a quiz show for
the employees
at 7pm once every month you know just do
a random email at night when you're
feeling the culture's a little down and
say everybody on this zoom link at 10
a.m tomorrow
and just shoot the [ __ ] you know like
be human i mean it
any final words of wisdom before we we
wrap up and thank you again so much for
your time and all this
wonderful insight content
is the unlock it just is you may not see
it you may not think you're good at it
you may not want to do it
but it's been so consistent and obvious
that it will continue let me show you
something real quick
you think zoom and tick tock and
instagram are crazy
this is coming eventually when it's
humongous as big as i'm going to predict
right now i don't think it's going to be
some huge
device that's going to be like this i
think it's going to be closer to contact
lenses are much smaller
but in the next 15 to 30 years we will
live in a vr world and you're going to
think the iphone
and tick tock was child's play you will
be in virtual conferences
you will be doing virtual meetings you
will you will
and if you're 60 right now and you're
watching be like good i'm not going to
deal with that i'm going to retire
that's fine i understand but the thesis
remains
figure out how to be human figure out
how to bring value figure out how to do
content
and this i think of this is this is a
marathon this is coming
so how do you train for a marathon well
you run on the treadmill every day to me
linkedin
and and instagram and twitter and making
content starting your own podcast
this is this is training for the race
this is training for the race
i really really need you to train for
the race it's how all of society is
going to be structured
definitely business that's amazing
thank you so much again to everybody
who's listening
definitely go check out garyvee this
keynote was fantastic there's so much
that each one of us can take moving into
2021
to make this the best year at datto and
the best year as a team that we'll ever
have
um and gary thank you thank you for your
time and the great answers
and just you're wonderful thank you so
much thank you
thank you so much i see some of your
tweets i'm going to try to get into
during the day
garyvee if you have a follow-up question
i love all of you healthy2021.
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon